you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cop 26 in glasgow
where two major commitments have been
announced today
around 100 nations sign up to a promise
to slash methane levels by 30 percent by
2030
while a similar number of countries
including brazil and indonesia pledge to
end and even reverse deforestation again
by 2030
like the advance of burnham wood
at the end of shakespeare's great
scottish tragedy let's work together not
just to protect the forest
but also
to ensure that the forests return
and uh i'm in the amazon where logging
is rife in recent years
our chief correspondent has been on the
road in the amazon reporting from a
highway that cuts a 1 000 mile gas
through the forest
this is a new logging area these are
huge trees look at this one up here it's
absolutely
enormous it's called
the summer momma
i mean it's at least 500 years old
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show live from the very
heart of the cop 26 summit in glasgow
now this conference is due to continue
until the end of next week but this
evening the two-day world leader summit
has concluded but as the politicians
leave and pass the mantle on to the
negotiators there were some notable
successes announced today
around 100 nations who together
represent 85 percent of the world's
forests have agreed to halt or even
reverse deforestation by 2030.
more than 40 world leaders including
those from the us india eu and china
have signed up to a new breakthrough
agenda in an effort to make clean
technologies the most affordable
accessible and attractive choice in each
of the most polluting sectors again by
2030
and more than 100 countries have pledged
to cut methane emissions by at least 30
percent before the end of the decade the
impact of methane on climate change is
more than 80 times greater than carbon
dioxide over 20 years but because it
only lasts in the atmosphere for about
12 years cuts in emissions can have a
much quicker impact our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter has
more on just what's been
agreed all smiles as world leaders and
global figures in the fight against
climate change prepare to head home from
cop26 in glasgow
there has been a barrage of
announcements america promoting a global
deal to cut methane
the royal family out in force adding to
a general sense of momentum
boris johnson focusing on a major
agreement to end deforestation by 2030
although there's some criticism that it
lacks teeth
there are concerns that brazil might
sign on the dotted line
but it's still got a big problem with
illegal forestry
what is your assessment of that
situation well you're not incorrect by
saying illegal forestry is a big
challenge but what we're bringing to the
table right now is a level of commitment
we cannot let carbon sinks be be just
taken away from us and if we do that we
have a shot at this 1.5 and i'm hoping
it's more than just a shot progress on
keeping 1.5 degrees of warming within
reach but a thorny problem persists as
delegates shuttle between meetings the
issue that permeates nearly every
discussion is money
poorer nations say that so far rich
countries have delivered too little too
late it is a fault line that threatens
this summit
china is very focused on this issue
delays to a hundred billion dollars of
global funding a particular concern
there is still a large gap between the
support required and
support provided
they
failed to deliver their commitment
before 2020 which has a
negative impact on the mutual trust
between developed and developing
countries u.s special envoy on climate
change john kerry knows that this is a
matter of credibility that more needs to
happen and quickly
a hundred billion dollars doesn't do it
folks
it's trillions of dollars that are
needed
and the only way we will get this done
is if trillions of dollars are
forthcoming and they are
tomorrow there'll be an announcement i'm
not going to jump the announcement
but there will be tens of trillions of
dollars announced
that are available to be invested
invested
in
this transition
for the climate vulnerable this is a
matter of survival
if we don't
turn the tide around now
there'll be no more islands
and then when there's no more islands
there's no culture there's no language
and they're gone
bill gates announcing millions more to
push green innovation along is hopeful
but realistic about the challenges ahead
if i look at
where we were six years ago where the
private sector was not being engaged not
providing its expertise and resources
and when we weren't talking about
innovation and how we were going to make
green products
cost
equal or even less than the products
they replace but i wouldn't
understand this is a hard problem
humanity has never done anything this
hard almost everyone gathered here
agrees
a monumental challenge at a critical
time
time that is running out
hannah thomas peter sky news at cop 26
in glasgow
and hannah's with me now will get her
thoughts in just a moment but first in
the past hour boris johnson has held a
news conference at the conclusion of the
leaders summit here and he seemed to
think that things were moving in the
right direction
we can be confident about one thing in
the days
ahead the couple of weeks we've got
the clock on the doomsday device that i
talked about is is still ticking
but we've got a bomb disposal team on
site and they're starting to snip
the wires i have some of the right wires
and
my message to them
to the negotiators is is very simple the
leaders of the world may have left or
are leaving cop now but i can tell you
that the eyes of the world the eyes of
the populations of the world are on you
in the eyes of the british government
and all the other governments that care
about this are on our negotiators and we
have your numbers
so hannah boris johnson and fellow
leaders are all heading away from here
heading out of glasgow tonight so what
happens next i think you're right that
there was a real sense that everybody
wanted to make their mark at this big
moment and they will go home perhaps
feeling they did manage to regenerate
some of the momentum that may have been
lost when the g20 summit in rome on the
eve of cop
fell short really when it came to
getting new commitments on coal and
phasing out carbon or getting carbon
emissions down to net zero
now the big row
turns to cash that is the fault line
underpinning the summit john kerry
promised trillions more in commitments
from big business in particular expect
that to be a real focus tomorrow and
watch
the reaction of developing countries
carefully to see if they finally believe
that enough is being done hannah thanks
very much indeed
well let's take you somewhere now where
the promise to end and reverse
deforestation will possibly matter more
than anywhere else on the planet my
colleague mark austin is in manaus in
the amazonian rainforest mark over to
you
yeah and another reason that it matters
more than anywhere else is this place is
one of the great carbon sinks or carbon
stores as they're called uh on the
planet but the more that trees are
removed and fallen and
logging takes place the less that is the
case and of course now uh this pledge
has happened from the um international
community including the brazilian
government that but there's great
skepticism uh whether um it will
actually materialize now over the last
few days here we've witnessed how the
urban spread is uh intruding into much
of the rainforest you can see there from
the air these settlements are springing
up a lot of trees have to go because
because of that much of it unregulated
on the ground you can see new roads new
clearings being prepared all of which
involve more trees being felled our
chief correspondent stuart ramsey has
been to toro in the brazilian amazon and
he sent this report
enormous trucks battle away through
clouds of dust on a rutted and cratered
road the br163
for 40 years this highway that cuts a 1
000 mile gas through the amazon
rainforest has been used to transport
beef corn soya and logs to the outside
world on an industrial scale
in its wake the forest has been
destroyed
this is para state in brazil's amazon
the open fields tell a story of mass
exploitation of natural resources but it
always starts with the cutting of trees
and despite worldwide condemnation it
continues unabated
driving the br 163 it's easy to see the
burning that precedes the logging that
will soon follow it's illegal but they
don't bother to hide it anymore
lori is filled with precious valuable
wood everywhere huge logs loaded on
board and taken away
we pull off the road into a newly cut
section of the forest
it's a graveyard of thousand-year-old
trees
burnt to weaken them and then cut down
the loggers will return at night
these trees are worth a fortune their
size is staggering
but they're all dead now
legal or illegal logging it makes no
difference these trees will never be
replaced
the forest can't defend itself
there's much talk about the tipping
point where the rainforest simply can't
continue to exist i'd have to say in
this part of the amazon they've reached
that tipping point this is a new logging
area these are huge trees and look at
this one up here it's absolutely
enormous it's called
the samama
i mean it's at least 500 years old it
could be a lot more it's been pulled off
to the side it's super valuable
we don't know where it'll end up it's
very possibly though going to end up
in a
shop
in europe or the united uk or the united
states
and we're not even hiding from the main
road here this is just cutting down of
trees in plain sight
most of what's transported on the br163
is at best murky but worst plane illegal
but the loggers the farmers and the
ranchers say it's transformed the
economy of paris state a transformation
more important than stopping climate
change
under brazil's president bolsonaro the
cutting has increased
many here doubt his cop 26 commitments
will actually make much difference
try irao nestles beneath the rainforest
it's the only town on the 163 that still
does
just 16 years ago though it was inside
the forest and all travelers pass
through it bringing trade
now it's off the main road the trees
have gone and nobody comes through
seventy five-year-old joao alves fedoza
says the road has been a disaster
is
the traffic on the 163 never ever stops
occasionally it branches off to the
tributaries of the amazon
rivers that are the lifeblood of the
rainforest replaced now by tarmac and
mud
a unique vital part of the world's
environment
cleared out by humans
where even the living trees now stand
alone
mr ramsey sky news in the amazon
well of course it's not only here in
brazil where the deforestation pledge
could have an impact the indian ocean
island of madagascar is another of the
countries that signed up to today's
announcement to reverse
deforestation by 2030 but extreme
poverty means many people on the island
rely on cutting down trees to make a
living as our special correspondent alex
crawford reports
we're at a cattle market in the deep
south of madagascar the grand sued but
the thing that's most selling out here
is huge amounts of wood
only 15
of the population of madagascar has
access to electricity it's one of the
poorest countries in the world despite
its huge amount of natural resources so
inevitably the people have turned to
chopping down trees to just provide fuel
they also not only use it for cooking
but for heating
they sell charcoal as well as wood to
try to create a livelihood most of the
population are living on
less than two dollars a day
as i say one of the poorest countries in
the world but it's led to massive
deforestation which in turn has led to
soil erosion they've lost
about 40 percent of their forest
since the 1950s which has added to their
huge environmental challenges
if you look around most of
the people here have arrived here by
cart or they've walked they're one of
the countries in the world who
contribute virtually zero to the carbon
emission problem globally and yet
they're feeling the most impact of
climate change with huge extremes of
weather cyclones multiple cyclones every
year as well as huge long droughts
they've had an extended drought just
recently in some parts of the country
it's lasted for four years in other
parts of the country they haven't seen
proper rain in nearly a decade so the
problems here are enormous for the
population of madagascar
and i've got to say anna there's huge uh
skepticism here that uh
this pledge will really mean much uh to
a government that has overseen such a
huge increase in illegal logging that's
it from the amazon for now back to you
anna
mark thanks very much indeed
well let's take a look now quickly at
some of the other developments here
today at cop26 and ecuador has announced
plans to expand the marine reserves
around the galapagos islands by 50
percent speaking of cop 26 president
guillermo lasso confirmed the new
reserve will be 23 000 square miles in
addition to the existing area of around
50 square miles
demonstrators got creative outside the
conference venue today with squid game
themed protests some wore costumes from
the hit netflix show while others put on
face masks of world leaders as they urge
them to stop playing games with the
climate
prince william has met the first winners
of his earth shot prize the
environmental award aims to find
solutions to the world's biggest
problems and this year's winners and
finalists were introduced to industry
experts with a view to gaining support
for them to start producing their
innovations
and one of those finalists was 14 year
old vinisha umashanka who developed a
solar-powered ironing card as a clean
alternative to the charcoaled powered
street irons the press clothes for
millions of indians every day
we hope that you will give up the old
ways of thinking and the old habits
but let me be clear when we invite you
to join us
we will lead
even if you don't
we will act
even if you delay
and we'll build the future
even if you are still stuck in the past
well we're getting straight to
discussing the issues of the day now
with senior policy advisor for the
environmental think tank e3g jennifer
tolman and peter betts an associate
fellow at chatham house who has in the
past been lead climate negotiator for
the uk and the eu so welcome to both of
you so jennifer first of all day two of
the leader summit they're all heading
off now
some
big announcements around today many have
called them what stood out for you
i think we're seeing one step forward on
the really hard to do stuff
but a lot still to do including here at
cop for the next two weeks but then also
to pick up from the g7 and and from
leaders going home and actually having
to implement this stuff having to
deliver on their promises well let's
look at two of the announcements uh
peter we've had um this commitment by
more than a hundred world leaders to end
and reverse deforestation we've also had
a global partnership to cut methane do
those feel important to you
stopping deforestation would be a major
contribution to tackling the climate
issue and
could make a substantial
contribution to putting the world on
track for 1.5 degrees
of course it's going to have to be
delivered we've seen these pledges
before but i think
you know one can draw confidence from
the elements of the package finance
available
through public and private sources
supply chain commitments
to encourage deforestation free
production so i do think it's
potentially very significant similarly
the methane initiative
methane a lot a lot of methane emissions
which is a potent greenhouse gas from
for example from distribution networks
for gas it actually would save money
often to capture this methane people
don't do it so potentially if and it's a
big if these commitments are delivered
they can make a significant contribution
to get it putting us on track jennifer i
don't know if it's helpful to do this
but would you say that one was more
significant than the other
i think it really depends on how they're
implemented so at the end of the day a
commitment is only effective if you
actually go home and put the legislation
in place i think both are significant in
different ways i agree with with pete
that on the forest front it is an
incredibly important piece this is the
first time that the cop is really
talking about this in a in a more
political way and the piece that i'm
really interested to see is how does
this get picked up by the g7 are we
going to see a g7 initiative on
deforestation free supply chains
building off this global call i think on
the methane front it's an incredibly
important signal on something that
really hasn't been
committed on before but
some of the big emitters still aren't in
the mix so china india russia and that
is really the next frontier can we bring
these countries on board well yes and
with that in mind the the ambition is
relatively low you could say it's a cut
of 30 by 2030. is part of that the hope
that some of those countries might come
on board
i think it's i think it's focusing on
those emissions which
which appear to be doable very quickly
and and you can get general consensus on
it on the energy sector particularly
aren't they in particular because a lot
of the uh methane emissions come from
agriculture for example which is a
harder issue to crack and why is that
harder
it's just that the technologies are more
complicated it's about you know
different diets for for animals
it's it's a much more complex uh issue
would you agree with that is it
politically difficult as well for
for governments to say to people we're
going to have to change the way we farm
because of the problems with the
environment i think it is and i think
one of the biggest uses the the
solutions aren't as transferable like
most energy systems are fairly
centralized so you can definitely talk
with each other about how you're going
about it
agricultural systems vary so widely
across the world whether you're doing
kind of big industrialized farming or
smallholder farming and the solutions
are going to have to be drastically
different
so it is a really big question one of
the big questions is how do we actually
put money behind the shift what is going
to be the role of things like
development banks
and i think that's also the next step
and what about looking ahead we heard
from john kerry today that he felt that
the 100 billion dollars a year that
should have been forthcoming by last
year still the money isn't together he
felt that could come together by next
year rather than 2023 as previously been
said how promising is that and could
that make a difference
to developing countries feeling they're
being heard here
it's clearly essential we meet this
hundred billion dollars and it's
unfortunate that it it wasn't met by
2020 okay there were exceptional factors
in 2020.
my sense is there will be very strong
pressure
from developing world to demonstrate
that this 100 billion has been delivered
on average every year up to 2025 so in
other words we would have to exceed the
100 billion significantly
in after 2023 to compensate for the
short force i think that that is
necessary for the trust you know
developing countries look at the
trillions that we spent in our own
countries responding to covid and yet we
couldn't deliver this 100 billion
commitment that was made
in 2009. so that could affect the days
going forward and another development
jennifer that you are saying is
significant but hasn't received a great
deal of attention talk to us about that
i think there are really two i think
there is one which is about what leaders
are asking ministers and negotiators to
do in the two weeks that we still have
left here the game is nova um and today
we saw 28 world leaders including
president biden including chancellor
merkel and and president macau
actually say all right what we need you
to do is we need everybody to come back
with updated plans by the next cop which
is an immense achievement they also got
behind doubling the current amount of
adaptation financing that as a goal and
the question now really is what can
ministers do with that how can they take
this and actually bring it into a text
that is
signed by 193 countries
okay well we must leave it there but uh
jennifer tolman and peter betts so much
to keep looking out for over the next
week and a half but for the moment
thanks very much
indeed you
so that's two days done of [ __ ] 26 and
the end of the world leaders summit but
it hasn't just been about the leaders
making the speeches and chairing the
conferences so here's a quick flavor of
what else has been going on here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
god bless you all may god save the
planet
and don't forget you can listen to a new
climate cast every day from cop26 that's
wherever you normally get your podcast
from and you may well be watching this
already on our pop-up channel but if
you're not you can find uninterrupted
coverage from cop 26 between 9am and 7pm
on channel 525 all week
but do stay tuned with us here on sky
news we've got sky news tonight coming
up next with jonathan samuels with much
more on cop 26 from here in glasgow